au brésil à présent l'étau se resserre
sur le président brésilien ball sonar ou
la commission sénatoriale qui enquête
depuis deux mois sur les défaillances de
la gestion de la pandémie par le
gouvernement brésilien poursuit ses
auditions
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite à augusta lunar dit journaliste
indépendante en direct de sao paulo un
bon soir de sa la commission sénatoriale
qui a donc pris connaissance de
nouvelles révélations qui met à mal le
cambodge hoarau oui bonsoir exactement
cette commission sénatoriale a pris
connaissance d'un scandale financier qui
vient entacher le mandat de gérer le
sonar ou trois sénateurs brésiliens ont
demandé lundi dernier à la cour suprême
l'ouverture d'une enquête contre le chef
d'état accusé d'avoir fermé les yeux sur
des soupçons d'irrégularités dans
l'achat des doses du vaccin
un conte vaccine du laboratoire indien
barak
pardon baratte bio tels selon la presse
brésilienne barak biotech avait
initialement proposé le vaccin à 1 $ 34
par dose alors que les vaccins que le
vaccin n'avait pas encore reçu
l'homologation des autorités sanitaires
brésiliennes mais le gouvernement vole
sonar ou a finalement accepté de payer à
la place 15 dollar par dose soit plus
que pour tout autre vaccin qui n'est
jamais acheter donc hier soir un nouveau
scandale concernant l'achat des vaccins
anti corrida eu lieu le quotidien folha
de san paulo a révélé que dans le cadre
des négociations pour l'achat des
vaccins
astrazeneca entre le ministère de la
santé brésilien et le groupe
pharmaceutique da vaty un pot de vin de
1 dollar par dose
or était exigée par la partie
brésilienne en échange de la signature
du contrat
selon le journal le directeur de la
logistique au ministère de la santé et
est impliqué le gouvernement brésilien a
annoncé son limogeage
hier soir et augusta les opposants du
gouvernement molson à rouyn qui organise
d'ailleurs en ce moment brasilia le
dépôt d'une super pétition demandant la
mise en accusation du président
brésilien
oui exactement vérité plus les auditions
de la commission sénatoriale se
succèdent
plus les accusations s'aggrave le
gouvernement un bol sonar aux arrêts
j'étais des offres d'achat de plusieurs
millions de doses du vaccin father à
plusieurs reprises le ministère de la
santé a tenté de modifier la notice de
peu la chloroquine remet de
scientifiquement prouvé inefficace
contre lakovic 19 entre autres auraient
irrégularités commises par la gestion du
président brésilien et son gouvernement
face à la crise à lutter face à la
pandémie les représentants de 46 partis
politiques d'opposition sont en train de
déposer en ce moment au parlement à
brasilia une super demande de
destitution de bolton euro qui en plus
de vouloir responsabiliser son
gouvernement d'être plus des cinq
centres 1 1000 décès liés à la cause
l'éditeur va également apporter les
accusations de corruption dans l'achat
des vaccins au kovacs in et astrazeneca
donc on vous avait dit un rassemblement
est en train d'avoir lieu en ce moment
devant le congrès national à brasilia la
capitale du pays et des nouvelles
manifestations sont prévues ce week end
comme d'ailleurs tous les derniers
week-ends depuis trois ou quatre
semaines
les manifestants se réunissent partout
dans le pays pour demander bien sûr plus
de doses de vaccin car la vaccination au
brésil marche encore très très lentement
mais surtout la destitution du président
jaillir ball sauna est justement votre
son art au clairement contestée est un
risque pour son avenir politique
déjà est d'ailleurs en forte baisse ce
sont ces soupçons de corruption siebel
sonar en continu de protéger les
responsables et peut en effet en ruine
et son programme anti corruption s'était
à son bourreau un programme lors de son
élection en 2018 qui a d'ailleurs aidé à
les lire mais si les abandonne ils
risquent de rompre son alliance avec les
députés et les sénateurs de centre c'est
un groupe hétérogène de parti
conservateur qui lui a notamment permis
d'empêcher la progression parlementaires
de plus de 120 pétition de destitution
contre lui mais une chose est claire la
popularité de bolton arrow est en baisse
est en chute depuis plusieurs mois
depuis plusieurs semaines aussi à cause
de la pandémie bien évidemment mais à
cause de l'augmentation du taux de
chômage de la pauvreté de la population
qui aussi à cause de la fin de l'aide
d'urgence versé au brésilien ou tout
premiers mois de la pandémie
non rien laitiers en deux depuis le
début adieu mamba de germolles sonar ou
en 2019 plus de 120 demande de
destitution ont été déposées mais la
procédure ne peut pas être ouverte que
si le président de la chambre basse
décide de la soumettre au vote et ce
président étant donné qu'il est en fort
et allié de bolton à rouen le scénario
est encore imprévisible il faudra
attendre encore quelques semaines
quelques quelques jours quelques
semaines peut-être avec beaucoup de
pression populaire le président de la
section pro bass voudra ouvrir cette
cette procédure de destitution de bol
sonar ou merci agosta vous n'aviez j'en
ai indépendante d'avoir été avec nous en
direct de sao paulo et c